60 minutes aired a wide-ranging
interview with Tillerson less than a
month ago Margaret Brennan asked him
about the possibility that he would be
forced out where do you think those
reports came from that you were
resigning or being fired I have no idea
where they come from
I really don't and I don't give it much
thought I mean you walk into ministry
meetings and reporters are shouting sir
when are you resigning I never hear
those questions you know the only person
that knows whether I'm resigning or not
as me
fascination moderator Margaret Brennan
joins us now Margaret was there a
specific situation here that caused this
rift or was it the list that the
president put forward well there has
been a list of policy disagreements but
in the past month or more the message
from coming from the State Department
from the Secretary of State himself
particularly to our allies around the
world was I'm staying that was certainly
the takeaway from our 60 minutes
conversation what I will say is there
seems to have been a trigger for the
president on Friday
Rex Tillerson I am told by multiple
sources found out he was fired when the
public did I know there's reporting that
says otherwise
while the two had policy disagreements
particularly when it comes to the u.s.
breaking commitments and you heard the
president mention one of those instances
he brought up the Iran deal it's
interesting that the president brought
that up
unprompted because we know he is facing
a May 12th deadline to make a decision
on waiving sanctions on Iran and
Tillerson and his allies have been
working behind the scenes diligently to
try to get a package in place so that
the nuclear deal with Iran can continue
to exist but perhaps get tougher the
president right now in those comments
highlighted that as a major point of
disagreement with the Secretary of State
he didn't answer questions on North
Korea and John I think it's really
interesting that in many ways this path
towards diplomacy that the White House
is now embracing with North Korea was
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson Spalla
see however he was not proposing that
the president be the point man on that
he was saying he would do the legwork as
you know foreign policy requires a lot
of people working
off the same song sheet where do things
stand now Rex Tillerson and Secretary of
State maddis had worked very closely
from the beginning their stories of that
HR McMaster and the National Security
Adviser might be have his job might
change so what's the state of the team
that needs to be on the field when this
important North Korea issue gets
resolved or not resolved well that's
exactly right you don't you don't change
teams right the head of the big game
right and you don't do it when the
person laying the diplomatic groundwork
is not in the office and people simply
don't even know who to call when we had
CIA director Pompeo on Face the Nation
this Sunday repeatedly asked the
question who is leading the charge who's
laying the groundwork so that when the
president United States walks into that
room with Kim jong-un he's armed with
the best facts the best policy and the
best way to accomplish what he wants to
get done that is the job of diplomats
and the CIA director simply could not
answer that question repeatedly said
it's going to be up to the president
he's the one calling all the shots here
so not only do you have an issue of thin
ranks at the State Department because
there are people not being put into
policymaking positions or not being
confirmed into those policymaking
positions but now you don't have someone
at the head of that organization and
they're trying to right now scramble to
figure out who's going to be taking the
lead particularly on Iran but also on
North Korea and it would seem to be that
it's the national security establishment
more of the intelligence agencies that
have the foot forward on the North Korea
path but right now the White House still
can't answer basic questions that you
raised we'll learn more about the the
Mike Pompeo of course the new Secretary
of State at his confirmation hearings
Margaret thank you for your great
reporting